الذين ولدوا مع قناه العربيه عمرهم عشرين
عاما لنستمع مجددا الى الشباب العربي في
فقره عمره 20 سنه
اضيف تطورات وخاصه الروبوتات بالمجال
الاعلامي ممكن نستفاد منهم بارسال لمناطق
النزاع وساحات الحروب
عوضا عن الصحفيين والمصورين يلي عم
بخاطروا بحياتهم يمكن انا عادي افتح
الكمبيوتر تبعي اتحكم بروبوت يروح عني على
الشغل ويعمل ادائي انا يعني وبعتقد اصلا
ما بيقعد في مدارس لانه التعليم هلا متجه
للاون لاين وللكتب الالكترونيه اللي هم
ايبوك العالم راح يشهد نقله جذريه خصوصا
مع دخول الويب 3 والذكاء الاصطناعي وهذا
راح يسهل شيء كثير
من الاعمال خصوصا في الجوانب الحياتيه لكن
الشيء اللي انا متاكد منه ومتيقن منه ان
العربيه راح تكون رفيق دايم لنا في
الابداع والاسبقيه
صوت حلو في مدن ممكن تغرق تختفي الناس
كلها هتفضل قاعده على بتتكلم بتشتغل
بيعملوا كل حاجه درجه ان هم ينسوا شكله
وشوش البشر على الحقيقه
كله راح يصير عبر اللابتوبات والجوالات
والمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كما اتوقع ان
يسود الاعلام الرقمي المؤسسات الاعلاميه
وان يكون هو شكل واجهه الاعلان بالمستقبل
ولانه بحس الحياه راح تصير كتير متطوره
اكثر يعني ما بتعرفوا ممكن نصير نقدر نروح
مثلا رحله على الفضاء بالعطله او اشي زي
هيك نطور فيك ايامنا الانسانيه من خلال
التطوع بالجمعيات او من خلال الاعمال
اليدويه والاحترافيه التكنولوجيا ما راح
تقدر يكون عندها هيدي الروح تقدر تعملها
امين
[موسيقى]
مدينه